That's the story the Pentagon's putting
out. That's what you you keep getting
fed, frankly, all this bull
from the Pentagon.
They're liars.
They you know, they lied about the
KC-135 that went down so some weeks ago.
They claimed that it had crashed midair.
It got it got taken out by a missile.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is soul is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting?
What? No. Sadaqah. Brothers and sisters,
Iera is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly. Yearly, hundreds of thousands
people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training what? Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that sadaqah jariya
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah. And support Iera right now
inshallah. Enjoy the video.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and citizens and
dear friends. So, Iranian TV has
officials of the Iranian TV have said
they've taken out 12 aircrafts. We're
going to be watching and dissecting how
that happened moment by moment and see
who is actually lying here. But before
that guys, inshallah, I hope you guys
are well. But please, before we get into
that, brothers and sisters, please
subscribe to our new channel Let's Play
a Game, a brand new podcast with amazing
guests where we ask them personal
questions and put them in the hot seat.
Have you or someone you know resorted to
magic to solve an issue because they
were very desperate?
Mhm. We've had many guests inshallah
which you can see on the screen. Go and
subscribe to the channel Let's Play a
Game. The link will be there in the
description. Let's go straight to the
video. Some breaking news. America might
have lied to us about the search and
rescue operation. And it seems like Iran
might have caused a lot more damage than
we're being told. But first, you need to
know that Iran has actually claimed
responsibility for shooting down the two
American C-130 cargo planes that America
claims they blew up independently. The
US said these cargo planes they were
using to search for those fighter jet
pilots got beached in the sand when they
landed in Iran and they couldn't take
off again. The US said because of that
they had to blow them up because they
didn't have time to rescue the planes
and they didn't want the technology
falling into the Iranians hands. But
over the last 24 hours since this
happened, we've gotten a lot more
information about this and some things
don't add up. In the wreckage, you can
actually see there's a lot of holes in
the wreckage, holes that you wouldn't
get from air strikes. These holes in the
wreckage actually coincide with what
happens when an air defense missile hits
a plane. When an air defense missile
hits a plane, it blows up next to the
plane sending out shrapnel that then
flies through the plane and puts holes
in it which causes it to crash. And
going by the US's explanation that they
just bombed the plane because it
couldn't take off, that doesn't explain
all of these shrapnel holes in the
wreckage. Of course, this hasn't been
confirmed yet, but Iran might have shot
down these cargo planes and the
helicopters. And Iran has claimed
responsibility for doing that. And so
what we might be looking at here based
on this shrapnel damage to these
aircraft is that Iran shot down these
cargo planes or at least one of them and
then the US blew it up to avoid anyone
finding out. And this is something that
really nobody is reading into and I was
looking at the pictures myself and I
thought that's odd. So I dug into it and
it looks like that might be what Well,
it might be because we've got a US
expert from the military if I'm not
mistaken who explains this. But before
we do that guys, let's watch this video
from a breakdown of what transpired that
day. How did Iran manage to bring down
three US aircraft in just a single day?
Well, it all started on 3rd April the
2026 when a formation of US aircraft
entered Iranian airspace for a deep
strike mission likely targeting inside
Southwestern Iran. The US believed it
had established strong control over
Iranian airspace, but it was a
miscalculation. The strike package
included F-15E Strike Eagles, F-35
stealth fighters, an EA-18G Growler for
electronic warfare, and a KC-135
Stratotanker for midair refueling. As
the group passed over Khuzestan
province, Iranian air defense systems
detected the intrusion. Within moments,
Iran's Khordad system launched two
medium-range missiles guided by infrared
tracking. One missile missed, the other
didn't. It struck an F-15E sending it
crashing into Iranian territory. The
remaining aircraft immediately aborted
the mission and So, this can mean when
it hit the F-15E and it was hit. I think
what Iran has done is a very calculated
move by giving the Americans as if they
are okay in that territory and that
they've taken their done all their
anti-missile aircraft missile. And they
then I think Iran has made a massive
movie here by letting the Americans
think that they can just fly casually
there and they thought, you know what,
send a few planes. Oh, it looks like
it's safe because we're not getting
attacked. And the Iranians were waiting
for the Americans to come with the whole
crew. When they came with the whole
crew, when the
the E-15C uh jet
uh um um was hit, they were like, "Oh,
hell no. This is a setup." Then they
abort the mission. But by then they had
to come back and rescue, but let's carry
on. retreated to safer airspace, but the
situation had already escalated. Both
pilots of the downed F-15E had ejected
and were now missing behind enemy lines.
The US immediately launched a combat
search and rescue operation to locate
both pilots of the F-15. Rescue
helicopters, special forces, and air
support assets were immediately deployed
flying at extremely low altitude to
avoid detection. Soon, one pilot was
located and rescued, but there was no
sign of the second. As news of the
downed pilot spread across Iran, state
media began calling on civilians to find
him. Iran even offered a cash reward for
his capture. This turned the situation
into something even more dangerous, and
it's now become the game of race.
However, rescue helicopters continued
their operation to locate the second
pilot. As helicopters were flying low,
civilians and Iranian small units
started firing, in which one helicopter
was seriously damaged and the crew was
injured. The US rushed to send an A-10
Thunderbolt aircraft to provide close
air support and eliminate small units.
However, a one shoulder fired missile
struck the A-10, and the pilot managed
to fly it towards Kuwaiti airspace,
where it crashed. Finally, the second
pilot was located, but another rescue
helicopter came under intense fire and
crashed at the site. With support from
F-35s, US forces managed to safely
extract all crew members in a single
helicopter, and that day turned into one
of heavy losses for the United States.
Well, there you go. That's a breakdown
of um what happened there. But, when we
go to the Iranian media, and then we're
going to go to an actual expert
explaining how what Donald Trump is
saying is an absolute lie. Here is the
media channel Iran's national media TV
station explaining how they took down 12
planes.
Okay, so they're they're they're
laughing and saying, "Okay, this is a
successful operation, yeah. Okay, this
is this is funny." They're laughing on
state TV. Look at this. And the thing is
one one thing that people don't notice
in the comment section is how calm they
are.
Very calm. No panic. Nothing. This is as
if they've got this whole thing under
control.
The US, and let's just bear in mind,
guys, uh the petrol prices that's
rocketing, and the uh the the cost of
living, and um this war, it's to protect
the few pedophiles, a group of
pedophiles in Epstein Island. This is
what This is This is what it boils down
to. Any time you see the petrol price is
going up, and you go and I go, and I'm
looking at it, just know that it is to
protect the few pedophiles like Trump
and Epstein, okay, who are connected to
Mossad to blackmail and use uh that
blackmailing against the the wealthy,
the the the powerful so they can go to
this war. This where it all starts from.
Let's carry on.
I'm not going to lie, these guys are
specific. They're literally telling you
the names of each one of those
helicopter, cargo plane, jets, whatever
it says. They go into detail. This this
doesn't look like they're
saying any lies.
No, they're telling me Americans No,
listen, this is real Hollywood. No fake
Hollywood, this is real Hollywood.
And they're not going to shoot me in the
head.
>> So you can see clearly they are talking
about for example how
American officials experts
ex veterans are saying that this is
chaos and they've been fired. Here is
one of those who is going to explain to
us exactly what is happening on the
ground and the lie that's being told.
Let's watch it for ourselves. plan
rescue operation you said
From what I understand there were no
American deaths in the rescue plan
rescue operation Yeah, but there could
have been deaths with the That's you get
you're being lied to Mario. You're being
lied to. Look, a C-130
um
and
just as a side note, I was hired by
Hollywood to be a consultant on
on the first A-Team movie.
And the the script writer in it had the
A-Team rush the cockpit of a C-130
and strapped themselves to the pilot
seat and hit the ejection button.
And I had to tell him I said, "Boy,
that's that's really creative writing
except there's only one problem. You
don't have ejection seats in a C-130.
It's a hard shell aircraft."
So when when that thing exploded and
crashed into the ground in the video and
that's not AI generated, none of the
crew got out. So there were crew there
were deaths. The the Pentagon is lying.
They're covering it up.
But from what I understand the C-130 was
blown up by the US forces
in the rescue operation to ensure enemy
forces don't take ship. So that's one of
the lies that we were told that
basically they landed and they couldn't
take off so they
bombed the plane themselves. Yeah, okay.
Here's what he had to say. take take
control of it. That's the story the
Pentagon's putting out. That's what you
you keep getting fed frankly all this
from the Pentagon.
They're liars.
They you know, they lied about the
KC-135 that went down some some weeks
ago. They claimed that it had crashed
midair. It got It got taken out by a
missile.
You're talking about the two KC-130 the
shuttle tankers that that collided. But
they also didn't lie about the
casualties there. They said everyone all
pilots they didn't that they they didn't
lie that nothing got destroyed. They
they made you know Well, no, that one
they that one they didn't lie. They had
a They had a convenient excuse for how
they came up with with a with a a lie to
explain how it came down. Oh, this is
just an accident.
These These guys didn't die in combat.
It was It was an accident. So sad
accident. But to admit that the
that the C-130 went down
and I cuz when it goes down and crashes,
nobody gets out. And there therefore
that wasn't a collision mid-air
collision. They couldn't couldn't
present it as such. They had They had a
lot of aircraft and that was just for
one one pilot. Look Look with this
This is a reminder of we're now
technologically at a stage where you
really no longer need pilots in aircraft
over combat zones. It It's an
anachronism because they're going to get
shot down and then if you're going to
try to rescue them, you're going to put
a lot more lives at risk.
A drone goes down, hey, the drone goes
down. That's a key point. Why are they
sending servicemen if they can use
pilotless uh
planes? Because Israel is sacrificing
them. They don't care. They don't care.
They say you should you should also just
die for Israel. There's no There's no
person to recover.
And and they can actually a lot of these
combat aircraft can be configured so
that they can be flown remotely. Not You
don't need a pilot in it. They can be
flown remotely. But that's it. Yeah, the
Pentagon's putting out the spin. Oh, it
was great. We Yeah, we lost a few
aircraft, but we destroyed those on the
ground. I mean, good god.
I you know
please. The the This is
the lies they're telling uh are off the
charts. Because again, we were just
told, "Hey, we obliterated all the air
defense. There's nothing left in Iran.
Iran can't shoot us down." And then
yesterday, the number of aircraft that
were lost were at least in addition to
the one F-15,
you had
at least one A-10, two Pave Hawk
helicopters that are, you know, sort of
souped-up versions of the Black Hawk,
and at least two C-130s. Well, if I
didn't know what he said, if I'm not
mistaken, that's about five or six
aircraft.
You can see that it's not far off what
the Iranians are saying cuz they they
are speaking on the ground as well.
So, and it shows you that the false
impression Iran gave to Americans, and
this is how they fell for this trap. And
that's why Donald Trump is losing his
mind. Okay. So, you lose five more
aircraft to rescue the pilot from one.
Yeah, that
That's a great success. Now, I mean, you
don't deny the the balls on the guys
that went in there that are, you know,
>> Well, that makes sense. If you're saying
five aircraft were taken down, and then
then five aircraft went to rescue them,
and they got taken down. It makes sense
to what the Iranian officials are
saying. It makes perfect sense.
>> EJs
and the pilots. And this is you had a
lot of Task Force 160 pilots doing their
thing yesterday. And they they are
exceptionally talented.
But, you know, you're fighting you're
fighting a war
where you're you're basically have
declared war on civilians.
And that's what That's what these guys,
with all their good work that they did,
that's what they're tacitly supporting.
They're supporting a war crime.
So, why do you think it's not likely
they destroyed the
the
the aircraft on the ground, the C-130 on
the ground? So, they made a makeshift
landing landing strip for the rescue
operation.
I'm not an expert, so why wouldn't they
destroy it if they say they couldn't
evacuate it or it was damaged? Okay,
explain to me how they made a makeshift
landing strip.
I I'm not As I said, I'm not the expert,
so Yeah, they didn't make a makeshift
landing strip. Those The The C-130s are
designed that they can land in difficult
terrain and and and take off. But look,
this um
the the video I you know, I can share
the video with you um of of this
fireball coming down. It wasn't a
missile.
It was an aircraft that was on fire and
crashed. And why we know it's a C-130
because the C-130s also carry an extra
load of fuel that they can be used to
re- to aerial refueling of these
helicopters, uh the Pave Hawks.
Uh so, uh you you know, the the United
Well, why the Pentagon's saying that?
They don't want to admit that the plane
got shot down.
Because if they admit that the plane got
shot down, that's contradicting the
commander-in-chief, Donald Bonespurs
Trump,
uh who
uh you know, then insisted that there is
no no more air You know, you don't have
any more air defense in Iran, so we're
free to fly wherever we want.
And yet yet you know, Friday showed that
that's just not true.
Well, there you go, guys. Subhan Allah,
you can see the lies of these pedophile
maniacs uh who are waging this war to
protect their own reputation and their
name. And I've said it before and I'll
say again, guys, this is um them
they're
uh them heavily heavily Subhan Allah to
protect their name and
uh from being tarnished. Uh they are
raping gray pink
American girls,
yes, to the Israelis and to others or
these this these dirtbag pedophiles. And
then they're using those photos to tell
them, "If you don't do what as we say,
we will use this." So, if you don't send
out your American children to war for us
for the our greater Israel project, if
you don't do that, then we will uh you
know, uh show them what you're really
about. And we're going to use your young
American girls and boys um
we're going to use them so we can
blackmail you. Then we're going to use
your children to go and fight the war
for us.
You can't make this stuff up.
Disgusting, vile people. May Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala deal with them. That's
why they hate Islam cuz Islam is the
only force that's standing against their
evil. Till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.